bonjour madame la sénatrice bonjour
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation à venir au lycée pour nous
parler du pouvoir législatif je suis
Julie la déléguée de classe et c'est moi
qui vais vous poser les questions la
France est une démocratie parlementaire
ce sont les sénateurs qui siègent au
Sénat et les députés à l'Assemblée
nationale qui sont chargés de discuter
modifier et voter les textes de loi mais
si on reprend depuis le début qu'est-ce
qu'une loi
une loi c'est une règle juridique
générale et un personnel elle définit
les droits et les devoirs de chacun et
s'imposent à tous il y a des lois sur le
travail sur l'environnement sur la santé
et tant d'autres ah oui les lois
concernent tous les sujets nous avons vu
en cours qu'il y en a environ 80 qui
sont adoptés chaque année concrètement
comment est-ce qu'elles sont faites ces
lois les textes de loi qui sont soumis à
l'examen des assemblées parlementaires
sont de deux types il y a des projets de
loi et des propositions de loi et il y a
une différence entre les deux on parle
de projet de loi quand c'est le
gouvernement qui propose le texte
initial
en revanche on parle de proposition de
loi lorsque le texte est proposé par un
parlementaire sénateur ou un député nous
on vient en cours que pour qu'une loi
soit adoptée elle doit être débattue à
la fois par le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale alors que fait le Sénat quand
il reçoit le texte
il commence par le confier l'une de ces
sept commissions permanentes qui est
chargée de l'examiner et de le modifier
et qu'est-ce que c'est une commission
exactement une commission c'est un
groupe de sénateurs qui se réunissent
par sujet d'intérêt commun l'économie la
culture Les Affaires étrangères nous
remercions pour votre présence devant
notre commission des affaires
européennes chaque commission est
chargée d'étudier les projets ou les
propositions de loi dans son domaine les
commissions additionnent régulièrement
les ministres quelle est la position du
gouvernement français sur ce dossier
important mais aussi des experts des
chefs d'entreprise des chercheurs des
associations et quand la Commission a
examiné le texte alors le texte est
débattu dans l'hémicycle en Science
Publique par l'ensemble des sénateurs
qui proposent des modifications sous
forme d'amendement et c'est un sacré
travail parce que chaque année le Sénat
adopte environ 2000 amendements
qui est contre il est adopté une fois le
texte modifié votez adopté il est envoyé
à l'Assemblée nationale celle-ci fait de
même plus le renvoie au Sénat et ainsi
de suite jusqu'à ce que les deux
chambres parviennent à s'accorder sur
une version
identique du projet ce système d'Alés
autour s'appelle la navette pour le
montant le Sénat a donc adopté pour
faciliter la recherche d'un compromis
une commission mixte par étape peut être
réunie elle est composée de 7 sénateurs
et 7 députés chargée de rédiger une
version commune du texte de loi et que
se passe-t-il si un désaccord persiste
si un désaccord persiste le gouvernement
peut donner à l'Assemblée nationale le
dernier mot mais si c'est l'Assemblée
nationale qui décide à la fin on
pourrait se passer du Sénat non pas tout
à fait en réalité les désaccords sont
très rares ça n'arrive qu'une fois sur 8
et même quand l'Assemblée nationale a le
dernier mot elle reprend quand même
certaines modifications souhaitées par
des sénateurs une fois que la loi est
adoptée les parlementaires peuvent
saisir le Conseil constitutionnel pour
qu'il vérifie si elle est bien conforme
à la Constitution qui protège nos droits
et libertés et si le Conseil
constitutionnel déclare la loi conforme
alors elle est transmise au président de
la République oui oui c'est le président
de la République qui va la promulguer et
qu'il la rend exécutoire par sa
publication au Journal officiel le
lendemain de sa publication la loi entre
en vigueur et nul n'est plus censé
ignorer merci beaucoup madame la
sénatrice
[Musique]